[Music]
hello everyone welcome to the last
session you made it whoo hi everyone my
name is Miss animal Scottie
and I'm Justin Graystone and we're both
customer engineers based out of London
so what is the customer engineer well we
work with customers to design and build
solutions for the club and to be honest
we still see a lot of customers
struggling to deal with their monoliths
and they're trying to figure out how to
migrate them to a micro services world
so you guys look to be very tech savvy I
mean you're here does anyone here not
know what a micro service is can you see
a show of hands well that's good that's
handy does anybody here right I want to
I'm gonna do the reverse right who knows
what a monolith is okay we got a good
show yeah okay I'm gonna do some more
data extraction okay so who here as part
of your day job works with the monolith
okay that's that's quite a few of you
Wow
okay now this is a select group but
we've all been here who here secretly
knows in their heart of hearts what they
work on is a monolith but everybody else
decides to ignore the fact that is a few
that's that's good that's good
okay so right we're gonna try and we
haven't got long and it's a massive
topic but we're going to try and do
today so we're gonna walk through an
example and hopefully give you some some
tips but while we're doing this what
we're going to do is we're going to use
serverless compute now obviously there's
been some great announcements this week
you know that opens up server list of
Cooper Nettie's and gke but surplice
really enables us to concentrate on the
migration and not the standing up of the
DevOps we just want to be able to
migrate and scale so let's kick off and
start looking out on monolith alright so
one of the applications have several
things in common they tend to be
standalone isolated they're self
contained in the sense that all the
logics contained within a single
instance or a single unit and they tend
to be large and very complex to work
with and a lot of the time it's even
difficult to figure out where do you
actually start when we want to
understand how your application works so
we realize that this is a very
opinionated topic and there's a lot of
content out there we're gonna be
focusing on showing you a few examples
showing you a few techniques on how to
break off different parts of the
monolith convert them to micro-services
and hopefully this is something you can
take with you to your organization so
we're gonna start with as an example
we're gonna be using an e-commerce
application why an e-commerce
application well we think that a lot of
the properties in this application
resemble other monoliths out there so
there's a user interface that's
generated for the user to see and
interact with we have a load balancer
that handles requests from different
locations and distributed them among
instances all the application logic is
contained within a single unit state is
associated with within the instance
itself and in terms of storage well
you're probably using something really
ancient as a catch-all solution for all
your data may be something like a
relational database so let's take a step
back and think when do you actually want
to move to micro services like what
motivates it there are several good
candidate applications that are good for
micro services web applications for
example have they tend to be simple but
require the ability to handle a lot of
traffic so you need to scale enterprise
applications tend to be a lot more
complex very huge and they tend to be
applications that need to do everything
but what drives it in the end it's the
business requirements essentially what
does the business actually need to
succeed does it need the application to
be scalable such that it can handle
increased requests and volumes of data
or do you need to be able to optimize
the application
that you would only be using the
resources that you actually need or is
it more about being able to remain
competitive and have the ability to
develop features very quickly so you
need high development follows velocity
there are a lot of reasons let's look at
an example to showcase this better so in
our model this is our monolith and has
all the main components has a UI a load
balancer application and application
instance and a database and imagine that
you have a celebrity that tweets about
one of the products that you you're
selling on your e-commerce application
and let's say that - it goes viral so
suddenly you have a huge number of
requests coming in for people searching
for that product wanting to put it in a
shopping cart and maybe purchasing it as
well so you need to be able to handle
this these this increase in volume of
requests what do you do you scale you
can scale vertically that will only take
you so far so you have to scale
horizontally this is how it would look
basically you're adding application
you're adding instances but think about
this for a sec what are you doing here
you're replicating the whole application
on inch each instance do you actually
need that the scenario might only need
you to scale certain bits but you're
scaling the whole application which
means you're using a lot of resources
that you don't actually need and at the
same time we said that states associated
with the application instance how do you
do that well you can set up the load
balancer to have a sticky session with
that instance for any very specific user
but if what if that application instance
falls over then everything's lost for
that user you could move the state to
the database but then you're
overwhelming the database even more and
if that falls over you have a whole set
of other problems to deal with so
imagine that you also want to be able to
add features and let's say you do a
small UI tweak but because this is a
monolith you actually have to deploy the
whole application and let's say you made
a mistake the whole your whole
application goes down because the
simple UI tweak and there's nothing you
can do about it the thing is here the
main idea behind micro-services is that
it helps you bypass all that because it
gives you ability to do partial
deployments published in small
iterations and it gives the ability to
better handle scale and optimization so
all good reasons to move to micro
services but should we micro service the
world I mean does everything need to be
in micro services so this is a talk
about migration to micro services but
one of the things you've got to do
you've got to make sure that you sense
check that you're not just following the
internet or what somebody else has done
you know if you're not trying to fix a
problem of scale or optimization then
what are your motivations to go into
microcytic implicitly thing
well micro services may not actually
make your life any easier I'm sure most
of you are aware of that you might be
running specialist software or hardware
or maybe both like would you then go to
micro services what you're actually
gaining and just like you've got to have
the business reasons to move to micro
services well let's think of the
business reasons to stick with the
monolith like if you're one of these
serving the business well it's secure
its stable then what is the business
motivation and I think anybody who
undertakes this journey is going to
require a lot of money time and
emotional toil you must make sure that
you Chet sent check first
but with our example with our web app
and our e-commerce app we're taking this
scenario that we actually it was built
some time ago and we had a regional
customer base and now we've gone global
which is great
but the problem is is our systems now
suffering from stability and deployment
issues that Hussein is just highlighted
we've also noticed that our customer
customer competition is outperforming us
they're deploying new features faster
than us and they're eating our breakfast
so we have plenty of justification to
move to micro services so let's begin
so what we're gonna do is start by
focusing on capabilities
what are capabilities they're
essentially what the application does or
what the code does not what the code is
code can be rewritten refactored a lot
of the time you're gonna have to rewrite
stuff from scratch that's not the point
here what we need to focus on is being
able to take these capabilities that are
in your current monolithic application
and move them to your micro-services
application so that's going to be the
focus of this discussion so what
capabilities are going to talk about
we're going to talk about a bunch that
are common among monoliths as well
storage do we actually stick with one
database or look at several we're gonna
be discussing what we call as edge
capabilities these are ones that can
easily be detached from the monolith
we're also going to be talking about
sticky capabilities please keep you
stuck to the monolith and we're gonna
also talk about networking it does send
in the sense that how the different
parts of our application actually talk
to each other so let's take a closer
look at data and our data store in our
monolith application in the e-commerce
application we had one data store for
everything which is relational what
happens when you have both an increase
in volume in the number of requests and
the amount of data you still you need to
be able to scale to handle a lot but
it's relational so you can only probably
scale it vertically I've actually seen
customers trying to mimic horizontal
scaling by separating by creating
multiple database instances and then
charting the data across them and then
writing some logics to try to figure out
where the requests would go that's not a
good idea don't do that and I've also
seen some customers that actually take a
no sequel database but then use that as
a catch-all solution which still doesn't
help and try to write some sequel
queries over that that also doesn't work
very well
the idea is you need to think about the
problem you're trying to solve and the
right solution for it it could be
multiple solutions not a single solution
so what do we mean by that imagine that
you have a huge increase in the number
of users and the number of products
let's say a few million users and
hundreds of millions of products how do
you deal with that what do you use how
do you store that you can use a no
sequel database something like a
document database that would fit very
well because for each you can have these
little documents and each document would
be the user or the product and any
number of properties that's a good fit
what if you want to be able so that's
one solution what if you want to be able
to let's say be able to achieve the ten
thousand or thousand most popular
products then you need an in-memory
database something like that acts like a
cache for your hard data what if you
want to be able to see what the user is
actually doing in terms of where are
they clicking what are they searching
for what are they purchasing and maybe
use that data to try to predict what
they're gonna be doing predict what
they're gonna be buying that's where a
data warehouse solution would fit but
something like bigquery what about the
other stuff that might still fit well in
your sequel database stuff like
transactions which relational databases
are kind of fit for you can keep using
that for for those kind of transactions
but look at a managed solution there are
a lot of those on the club now
one thing also to mention is that do we
want to actually start by implementing
all these different no sequel solutions
but in a married database right away
built up or set up a data warehouse that
seems like a lot of work and you don't
really want to do this in one go you
want to do it in in an iterative way
such that you're not overwhelming
yourself so the idea is you have all
your data sitting in your legacy store
and as you move forward you chip away
different parts find the right solution
to solve that problem and use that
solution to solve that problem
what about edge capabilities these are
capabilities that are easy to migrate
are sort of their low-hanging fruit or
easy wins let's say they have certain
properties that kind of make them stand
out one thing is that their stand alone
in the sense that if you detach them
from the monolith or break them off the
monolith they don't really break the
models itself at the same time they have
minimal dependency back to the monolith
so let's look at a few examples image
upload that seems like an easy thing to
do all you do is basically take an image
and push it to a storage location that
can be a service on its own that just
responds to requests can even be an
external service that's something that's
not really tied that much to the
e-commerce app that we have another
example is thumbnail creation that's
also something that can easily be
detached without much dependency back to
the monolith both of these are easy easy
services to do that let's look at
something a bit more complex we're going
to be looking at one that is not easy
it tends to be everywhere when it
shouldn't be everywhere
any ideas it's gonna be your HTML CSS
and JavaScript
what is that essentially that's your UI
think of it this way you have this big
monolithic application and in different
parts of that application depending on
the feature or the capability you're
gonna have HTML CSS JavaScript embedded
there and the UI that the user interacts
with is kind of a combination of all
that HTML CSS and JavaScript from all
across your monolithic application so
what do you do here how do we actually
break this off to microservices so the
idea is we need to have all that HTML
CSS and JavaScript basically all your UI
code in one service so let's do that
here we have it a monolith and a new
service called the front-end UI that's
running all the earth UI logic it has
all the CSS JavaScript and HTML but
there's a problem here any ideas the
thing is it doesn't actually tie back to
your monolith it's a standalone service
so it's static the UI doesn't really do
anything so how do we deal with this we
need some sort of API layer on the
monolith such that front-end UI can
interact with that layer and that layer
would interact with the different pieces
in the monolith maybe how its showcase
here in the different capabilities so
how it's something like that looked like
something like this
where you're looking at each capability
or each part of the monolith where he
extracted that HTML CSS and JavaScript
and have some sort of API interface to
interact with it that seems pretty neat
we didn't really have to change that
much quote and we managed to separate a
service all and so on but there's a
problem here
does anybody know what that is maybe
Justin knows what that is
okay so this takes us onto sticky
capabilities that sounds a bit gross
really doesn't it but what do we mean by
sticky capabilities well they're hard to
pull from the monolith if you can
imagine a piece of gum and you're trying
to take it you're always being pulled
back to that monolith now why are we
being pulled back well the coach you
might take an approach where if you had
nice modular code you can go and stick
that and create that into a sort of
service maybe not a micro service that
could be great
but actually some capabilities here you
know monoliths their code it not
necessarily nicely encapsulated it so
we've also got state state could be in
memory in the data air in the monolith
it could be in the database you know if
we want to create a service we need to
be able to have have that stateful
stateless service and we need to be able
to not have to go back to the monolith
we want to actually move the capability
completely away from that monolith okay
so these were the capabilities we've got
in our system we've got rid of the ueq
UI the main UI that's gone he sayings
also found a couple of edge capabilities
there maybe more than that but we're
gonna get rid of those and who's near a
microphone right who wants to take a
shot and this is really high level
there's no detail of the system who
wants to maybe point out what they think
might be a sticky capability in the
system anybody
don't be shy authentication yeah great
yeah okay maybe search well
identification that was the one I was
looking for and we're gonna we're gonna
come to that the reason why it's because
of the state so there's a few others
that we identified now we'd hoped that
you know if you work you've got teams
working on a monolith they should know
the code so there should be some easy
wins like they should really understand
it but for this point for the point of
this exercise you know some of these are
really high level I mean like what agile
tasks do I mean that could be bash
scripts doing who-knows-what which is
absolutely critical for the monolith to
stand up how does that turn into a
market service you know stock trade
stock tracking shipment management
returns management that all sounds very
stateful we're gonna have to track
things maybe we're having to talk to
other systems all of these things and
not edge capabilities all of these
things you're going to have to look at
breaking them down and really understand
what it is they need to do and how we
can move the state to somewhere else
because we don't want to be coming back
to this monolith the other one that's
whatever the databases and then in our
case it's this single large relational
database I've seen a couple of
migrations from monoliths to micro
services where all the mana mana left
code is completely gone and maybe
there's people here that all echo know
this kind of scenario all that codes
gone monolith is deprecated but what's
still there in the middle of that is one
single large database which is actually
the Phantom legacy of the monolith
because it wasn't tackled while you
migrated and although we don't want to
do like as Hussein pointed out we don't
want to go ah there's all these database
technologies it's gonna be great every
single micro service let's use another
one it's we don't want to do that but we
do want to do is as we start to pull
these hard services out we need to
really consider how we move that state
to somewhere else like whether it's in
memory no sequel
but you want to consider that as you go
right don't try and do it all at once
say then then we got you source points
so you thought the monolith he's handing
in the lot handling login its Hanley log
out its handing session management so
like how are we going to deal with that
well let's take that one first so we had
this notion that we can put API is
everywhere but there's a big problem
with this well we haven't actually moved
it from the monolith we haven't actually
done anything the API we've just created
an API here and we really want to make
sure that our platform going forward is
on the left-hand side not in the
monolith so let's move it over there how
do that that was very easy I press a
clicker and number users over there I
want one of these so how do we do that
well if you are lucky and your monolith
has nice and capsulated code all nice
and modular maybe you could just lift
and create a mini monolith which just
handles the authentication you could be
we could use maybe you could still use
that database maybe you could take the
user user tables out of that database
and just have a smaller relational
database you know you just keep that as
a domain-specific database we didn't do
that we decided to use firebase source
and it's not necessarily a pitch just
for firebase or theist because it's it's
Google this you know you could choose
anything but what we chose is to move
completely away from the monolith now
we've got all these users over here but
with firebase we can use the CLI tool to
import those existing users and to
firebase sauce now the reason why we
chose this is because actually it was a
lot less work and it gave us extra
benefits so it fully broke us away from
the monolith we're no longer going back
to that model if for anything it gives
us more login options for very little
effort we didn't have native apps before
but now we can and we've got one single
authorization plane and it potentially
gives us real-time possibilities in the
future in our clients we wanted to so
how does this actually work well we have
a user API we've we've created an
interface that everything is going to
use going forward for your IR you
user authentication and on there it's
basic using the admin firebase admin SDK
Toth authorize we've got another little
benefit here because our monitored
monolith was using such session cookies
but firebase uses JWT tokens and JWT
tokens are a really great way to pass
identity between microservice calls a
session cookie would not be so great um
so that's what we what we chose to do
but we have another problem it's always
problems isn't it we have a problem now
because we created all those api's for
the you know quick wins for all the
different capabilities and the monolayer
to get a front-end UI work working and
what we've done is we've broken it by
taking users out the monolith not great
so how do we fix that well we thought of
a few different scenarios we could put
the e firebase admin SDK all over the
monolith that sounded like a pain well
we wanted what we chose to do it was we
altered the monolithic code to be remote
procedure calls out to our new you now
new user service and what this has done
is now that's flipped the situation
instead of auth being pulled back to the
monolith now the monolith is going to
our new service environment that's a big
win because once you've done that it
makes it easier to migrate other
services there's one more thing to do
with all so one important thing to
remember is that office atomic what does
that mean let's take a step back and
think about this every request coming in
to your application needs to be
authenticated and in fact a lot of the
requests between services need to be
authenticated as well why because now
you're you don't have one monolithic
application you have these micro
services talking to each other over a
network so there's more into it in terms
of the added network latency because of
this network latency is has a huge
impact on how your application would
behave think of this scenario you have
your mic monolithic application
and whenever you sent requests to it it
responded at a certain rate or a certain
delay with a certain delay now that you
went to micro services you're actually
seeing a bigger delay that shouldn't be
the case but why it's because of the
latency that's added there are a number
of things you need to think about how
many services do you have talking to
each other like do you have a continuous
chain of one service calling the other
that would reduce a lot of introduce a
lot of latency you need to think about
location are your services talking to
each other across the Atlantic or are
they within a specific region they
should be within a region because having
them spread apart would add a lot of
latency as well you need to take
advantages of things like caching
because if you have services that
communicate a lot with each other each
time that's latency that's added then a
more latency so taking advantage of some
caching would reduce that and at the
same time you need to make sure you have
really good monitoring and alerting
because things will go wrong and when
they go wrong you need to be able to
figure out what went wrong because you
have a much more complex system now with
like we said services interacting with
each other over a network so you need
good monitoring and alerting to be able
to detect that we talked a lot about how
to actually take a monolith breakout
some pieces off and turn them into micro
services we also in the beginning Justin
said we should recommend using a server
less platform something that's
completely managed but we see that
there's a opportunity to talk about
event-driven architecture because it
gives you a capability to do things very
quickly especially since we're rewriting
a lot of stuff using event-driven
architecture can help us add a lot of
features or a lot of services very
quickly let's look at it let's look at a
few examples this is a case where we are
creating a user so what happens you get
a request create request that goes to
the user API and the user API does its
thing and updates the data
at the same time it kicks off a message
through our messaging cue pops up and
that triggers off a few functions
there's one function that sends out a
welcome email through the mailer API
another function signs the user off for
a newsletter for the newsletter and to
be honest you can add more and more
functions very easily and think about
this here
each function is actually add acting as
its own micro service because it's
isolated from the rest of the
application and it's doing providing a
service and it can scale based on the
demand because you're doing it on
functions which is a server less
scalable platform let's look at another
example you're uploading an image that
image let's say is uploaded to object
storage something like GCS and that
results in a trigger also kicks off a
bunch of functions one function to store
image URLs in the user profile another
function creates thumbnails from that
image and again you can add more and
more functions and each one of these is
actually as its own micro service and
scalable because it you're running it on
a server this platform that was very
easy to do there's also an opportunity
here to talk about event sourcing which
is essentially when you want to be able
to update state and update State in
different locations within us in a
sequence so look at this is an example
user purchases something that creates a
payment notification which tells the
card servers hey this product has been
purchased or this item has been
purchased that marks it and basically
kicks off a message that triggers a few
functions as well one function is
updating the purchase log which is in
some data data solution in this case
BigTable another function in the same
sequence updating State in a different
location like you know in the user
purchase database so see here we're
making use of things like functions to
design things very easily and when
you're building your new microservices
taking advantage of these sort of
patterns will help you a lot in terms of
being able to add new capabilities or
new features very quickly okay so that's
all nice nice big red slide when things
go wrong they will always so one thing
that's always mentioned in these kind of
things is the culture change that
happens if you're running a monolith dev
team to micro-service that dev team and
as we migrate more of those services
over to that left hand side team's gonna
you know that number is going to grow
yeah this case we may have like six or
wife that was six hundred and the teams
basically they take ownership of that
tech stack you know of where that
service is so right up to page of duty
now if you have 600 micro services how
on earth is the dev team looking after
user or going to having any information
about how the whole wider system works
one of the things you don't want to have
is dev teams that are working in silos
nobody likes that and that's never
productive so what we know is we're
moving to micro service and complexity
increases um and as they own the whole
of the surface what we don't want to
have is accidents we will have accidents
but we want to try and avoid them so one
one particular example of this is the
recursion problem hey service team a
team that looks after service a we're
gonna deploy a new feature great we're
gonna use service because that's really
cool we didn't know that service be
called service see that actually call
service a and now Hussein's latency
problem is is is yeah a real big problem
so how do we fix this now one thing
that's really important is the
developers document the service and I'm
not talking about inline documentation
with all of his developers did that all
the time not very good at this I'm
talking about like having some sort of
open an accessible place for every
single service as you migrate where
everybody knows where to find
Meishan about it what it does so what
you expect it to do what dependencies
has and include which sir other services
it calls and make it discoverable this
is this is not technical but this is
important
you know it's adding a lot of complexity
we keeps using that word complexity
complexity complexity and we're thinking
okay we've got the business
justification to move to micro services
but it's sounding like a pretty hard
long slog to meet America services so
why do it well and then a repurpose or a
real situation that happened to me quite
a few years ago I'm going to repeat we
purchase a brief kind of style it in the
e-commerce example but it was running on
App Engine
there was a small monolith right I'm
using datastore state was in memcache
you know and datastore it's a
distributed monolith it wasn't terrible
codebase quite small nothing no
surprises there you can see how old is
if any front-end developers are there
can you spot something I sort of which
takes us back
there's a nice grunt file in there that
really takes us back if you're not a
front-end of you probably don't care and
anyway so all of this had a simple
scripts that ran on the deployment
pipeline the future few minor tests
bundled up all the JavaScript blowed out
to App Engine and in this case we'd done
a major deploy two days ago you know it
wasn't on a Friday and it wasn't at 5:00
p.m. so we did have actually be the
ability to know that it wasn't going to
crash and it seemed to be performing
really well so great
we can't you start working on the next
features and I go home in the evening
you know where this is going right yeah
I go home in the evening go to bed
2:00 a.m. mobile goes off really unhappy
person on the other end of the phone
websites down
and I'm thinking hang on who's deploying
it to a.m. in the morning luckily being
a monolith I've got one place to look
and being an app engine I go straight to
the logs and I can see that there is one
file to break them all and it was config
py config py is not that nothing doesn't
sound that great
what was in there was some hockey code
nobody ever has that right we had some
hockey code that worked was in the
backlog to be fixed and to made less
hockey but because it worked it never
got prioritized and what that code did
is it told the front end what state it
should be in what mode should be and so
let's say for ecommerce it was on this
date from this date we should be in
Black Friday mode on this date cyber
monday you get it and this day bla bla
bla the problem was is in that deploy
two days ago somehow they got unnoticed
but some dev had changed the date to the
midnight the last date the midnight was
just passed and because there was no
exception around the error that whole
application went ah I don't know what
state the front intervene so I'm going
to show a nice 500 error and it's the
App Engine 500 error if you haven't got
a default template set up you know how
ugly that is luckily the app was easy
fix just fix the date deploy it up and
running no problems go back to bed well
we afterwards we did a quick post-mortem
there was two key things that we decided
that we learned out this alerting needed
to be much better why did our letting
need to be much better what a because
somebody had to phone me which wasn't
great because it was my boss you know
but the fact is is why did it take two
hours for me not to notice that well we
had front-end cache headers on all of
the logged out pages so all of the non
user sessions yeah looked like it worked
and at 2:00 a.m. there isn't very many
logged in users buying stuff so our
letting need to much better because we
need to know as soon as that happens
that we need to handle it and it was a
really terrible user experience the
first one is actually a lot easier in a
way when you have a single service app
engine if you had 600 micro services
running you know you need to really make
sure that you're alerting is better and
you can understand the problems ok so
what do we do next well we did we got
all the display logic stuck it in an
angular app and gave it its own service
complete hundred percent static no
python anymore the backend we quickly
made api's
everything I'm we had what I says less
mana left it was still a mana left it
just wasn't working quite the same day
no no display logic in it we still have
the same problem though right one file
one exception whole thing goes down but
we have a real good improvement now the
front-end client can go hey the backends
decided to die I'm going to show a
picture of a puppy or whatever you know
I can I can do something better than
they did any other than the you know the
default app engine page so what do we do
next
well we naturally started breaking that
up into domains specific API and this
give us the ability to you know more
intelligently handle errors and keep the
users unaware that everything's on fire
okay so so let's so we got six things
there and I'm gonna go back to this 600
things right that's going to be really
hard to merit manage the combination of
errors that possibly could happen in a
600 micro service environment so we need
your need to do I'd event identify your
critical paths in your micro service
environment environment so what does a
critical path look like well in us we
want people to buy things because
otherwise there's no money to pay for
the web development and we're all
unemployed so user comes through the
checkout page and the user cart service
there's the thing that tells what the
user has put in their car is down okay
well what we can do is we could have
multiple projects for App Engine and we
could have to ply our services out to
multiple regions and the client can go
ah I mean you're ceased I'm gonna try us
west okay that's okay what happens if
that that disappears okay
so what do we do now we need to make
sure that people buy things so shopping
carts anything these use cookies it's a
track and a multi-device here that
doesn't work so that's why we have the
surface but let's not discount it we
could use local storage when we could
keep the client keeping a record we
maybe we know and the two services are
out there actually we'll say a message
to say it may not be the latest
information but the key thing is the
users can carry on
and make that purchase and so you can
see there that it wasn't the micro
service team necessarily that actually
had to fix that it was the people who
were looking after the front and UI so
you need to make sure that that the
critical paths are jointly owned and
actually properly owned by the teams
that have effects you know don't be
blinkered down one technical path either
don't think no there may be multiple
solutions and the thing that should
drive those solutions should be the
business why is it you're trying to do
now I can see we're running running a
bit out of time so I'm going to speed up
okay so the user services was down right
that's really simple but actually why
was the user service down I'd use a cart
service it was because the user service
was out and let's say we didn't go to
firebase and we still had her at that
relational database that relational
database is out okay so now we have even
more teams on the critical path we have
the people looking after the database we
have to use a service what can we do
well you know we could have an explosion
of services dying because as Hussein
said the user service is atomic so now
we have lots of complexity and what has
just happened one service is down and
now whole platform is going out yeah
it's feeling like Michael said this is a
hard work okay so we'll file over to a
read replica
well limp on will be in read-only mode
we'll just we won't do logins then all
the clients will stop doing logins but
users they are currently in the system I
was fine
okay so region one we send to region to
region to use now sending both things
and yeah welcome to your self created
denial of service attack on region 2 and
everything is out hey I thought this was
a good idea right ok so let's just take
a step back a little bit things you
ought to remember again six services not
600 let's think how complex this is with
600 I'm not going to do that actually
let's keep it simple with six you can
see that actually request 3-2 even a
service that isn't directly relying on
it is going to be out everybody and has
to understand what the error situation
is and what you need to do is you need
to file fast what if you had
timeout set at like five minutes for all
these all the little crests will boom oh
that's okay we're using servlets right
we can scale
oh you're paying for that you know so
you need to fail fast you need to send
an error message so everything in your
system and it should be part of your
documentation to understand what it
should do in this situation in this
situation actually we're going to throw
in an extra piece of technology and it's
probably a good time to throw in an
extra picture technology when you're
going to use an in-memory database we
know we can scale that we could use
cloud memory store and we just we know
we know we're not going to das another
region so to do this maybe we use the
event sourcing idea we have two cloud
functions pushing to both databases what
we can do and the reason why the Amba is
we know the the user service knows that
we're in failover mode and it's going to
send an error message which tells
everything that we're overly only in a
read-only situation hopefully that's
given you enough time to restore that
database now if this was it user service
and it was me I would probably make the
in-memory database the primary database
and have another database as a fallback
because as you saying pointed out
earlier it was atomic it's going to be
very very chatty so the advantages of
having that really low latency is is
going to be important okay
speeding through so microservice and
faults there it's complicated right but
with that complexity we have more
options right we can safely say that
actually already even though that is
more complex we can give the user a much
better user experience if the user has a
much better user experience they're more
likely to stay with your website or your
platform circuit breakers if you all
know microservices I'm going to explain
what one of those are but it's important
that you have them and maybe a maybe you
limit the amount of languages you have
in your platform so you have
standardized circuit breakers you know
fail fast and have a plan B bulkheads
create partitions between your domains
make sure that when you have that
catastrophic catastrophic failure your
whole system doesn't
go down now the bulkheads thing comes
from boats you know where you put or a
submarine where you put a bulk bulkhead
between the different partitions to stop
the whole boat sinking but I want you to
take away like if you're going into your
board you're going to your CTO or you're
advising a customer to go into you Mike
you're going to go on this journey you
don't want to show them these slides
right because that may frighten them
right so how can you how can you explain
this migration process and handling all
of this
to a non-technical person okay so is
anybody's birthday today
no sure it's nobody's birthday um let's
say that your business objective is to
hold a volume of air this is this is
your volume of air thank you very much
this is your monolith and the volume of
air is your logic there we go
one error it's gone down sorry did that
land on your head this is bubble wrap
right we can hold the same volume of air
with our bubble wrap but wasn't it a lot
easier to understand a balloon or had a
nice shape we could understand it
Micra services I don't know what this is
it's like multi-layered but I'm holding
the same volume of air roughly caveat
big needle and probably if I get
addicted to puffing the cells you get
the point right we're only going through
those certain things and the rest of the
system stays stays functioning that has
got to be a ready objective and as you
migrate from your monolith with all of
the culture change and with everything
try and keep that in your head because
that's where you want to try and achieve
- uh without a pass you back hang on oh
yeah I've got one more thing well done
Hussein semantic versioning I've got
five minutes we get semantic versioning
everybody knows what this is yes anybody
doesn't know this put your hands up
don't
shai okay go look it up on the internet
it's right there I'll take a picture why
is it important why why am i doing that
and well because this is your contract
to everybody who uses your service you
never had to do this with a monolith
well actually you might have had a
version number but it could have been
kind of meaningless here if somebody if
that service team a wanted to use
service B they could see which version
they had started using you probably want
to have a deprecation policy throughout
the organization so you understand that
if somebody changes the major version
and they have a breaking change you know
you have a year right or six months or
whatever you choose to put that on the
backlog and get that changed in all of
their services without this you have the
classic problem of you know somebody
making a bright backward incompatible
change deploying that into production
get back to that situation where
everything dies so make sure you use
semantic versioning so let's review
where we are what have we achieved with
our monolithic application that we
started with the one that only had a
load balancer and and at one instance
and a storage data store we added a new
upfront UI we added a bunch of new api's
and migrated is something difficult like
off into a micro service we identified a
bunch of easy wins with the edge
capabilities and identify the difficult
ones with the sticky capabilities we
also looked at error handling and
identified what critical paths are and
right now we have a deeper understanding
of what the system is hopefully yeah
hopefully so what do we do next what's
after this you need to continue their
journey we don't really have my
full-fledged micro service system nor we
have a monolith we have something in
between the idea is take what we've done
here and iterate follow the same process
extract services extract capabilities
out turn them to micro services and it's
it's a continuous of a way to evolve you
kill different parts of the monolith and
create new micro services and do it at
your own pace to avoid any of the issues
we saw and one thing that's important to
think about is the cultural change that
will have on your culture change that
this will have this will impact your
organization your organization could
have been a monolith where you have one
big team that manages this monolith
application and we could have done 50
minutes just on now right yeah so and
right now what's gonna happen is that
you're gonna have services different
micro services and you're gonna have
different teams managing those micro
services as well so make sure to embrace
that because that's the best way to move
forward it's a good luck on your journey
understand why you're making the
decisions you are and be aware that
things will go wrong so be careful while
you're moving along go on your own pace
like don't try to do this all at once
this is an iterative process and make
sure you balance between business
motivations and whatever trade-offs and
risks you're taking
thank you very much for attending this
we have two minutes does anybody want to
do a QA
[Applause]
[Music]